the fight installed on this season of
Iron Fist is just wicked
it's so much fun and just at us my name
is Clayton Barbra I'm the stunt
coordinator for iron fist I come from a
fight background my whole life for this
season I wanted to come in here and do
something a little bit different there's
an edge to the choreography there's just
a kind of relentless visceral energy to
it I really set out to make a punk rock
song so we focused on rhythm and tempo
and things like that it's quite a
different style from season one the body
has evolved and it has changed and it's
gotten bigger and better
plantain has a very clear vision of how
he wants to look it's been a totally
game-changing experience I just said
that we just have to do it over and over
until you stop thinking about it you
just do it
Clayton wants to see the real actors
doing the stunts
and everyone has bought that a game
[Music]
every episode has a standout sequence
something coming Colleen it's something
bad
episode one was very interesting and
restaurant fight with Finn and Jessica
it really established it tone
easy the Kunlun fight at the beginning
with me and Sasha was beyond intense we
both really worked our asses off on that
and it broke us
but it looks great it's exciting for me
to do that in the action sequences to
push them to the limit and I think that
the audiences will really understand and
believe the action is one of the stars I
can't wait for people to see the season
I just really hope that the audience can
appreciate the work we've put into it
and can enjoy the fights of what they
are which is awesome
I'm Clayton barber when I choreograph a
fight I take what's on the page and I
bring it to life every punch kick and
block must be performed to perfection in
order to make action the star like this
this should be a little higher
[Music]
step out where we can see you
everybody it's Charlie don't you feel
like they should have released that as
the first trailer for Iron Fist season 2
like they really want you to know that
they doubled down and spent the money to
do good stunts and good martial arts
because it's Iron Fist you want it to
feel like a classic kung fu movie
there's a whole bunch of stuff going on
in this footage but I also wanted to use
this to explain what's going on with
typhoid mary just because she's such a
big new character from the Marvel comics
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
because that spider-man ps4 game is
dropping next week I'm also doing a
giveaway in all my Marvel videos for
that all you have to do to enter just be
a subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this this is a trailer for Clayton
Barbour the fight choreographer as much
as it is for the actual series itself
you've seen his work before because he
did the choreography for the Black
Panther movie which had awesome fights
and it awesome stunts in a little while
before that for the Creed movie which is
probably why he's wearing that Rocky had
so he is legit so I feel like he was
probably one of the first hires that
they brought on when they were retuning
behind the scenes for season 2 they
brought on a new showrunner and
completely changed the show so that's
why Netflix is throwing all this footage
out at you they just want to remind you
of all the stuff that they fixed from
season 1 I will be doing a non-spoilery
review early next week as soon as the
embargo is up but I love some of the
scenes that they're hyping up in this
but you have a whole bunch of Colleen
wing fight scenes this is all taking
place way down town in New York City
close to Chinatown but they did say that
all that Kunlun stuff that we've seen in
all the trailers
those are flashbacks so that's all
happening before season 1 just meant to
hype up the rivalry that's been going on
their whole lives together steel serpent
vs. iron fist but you're calling wing
fight scenes she was badass in the first
season so I don't think that there was
too much to correct with her character I
think they just wanted to bump up the
number of fight scenes that they gave
her in the complexity as well as pair up
with misty Knight for some daughters of
the Dragon scenes from the comics but
obviously like there are a couple really
important female characters this season
including typhoid mary if you have no
idea what's going on with her she's
being played by Alice Eve who you may
remember from star trek into darkness
she's a pretty notable actress she's
done a bunch of
their stuff but that's just like one of
the biggest movies that she's done
recently
she's an old-school daredevil character
it seems like what they're doing with
the character is is they're using that
moon night twist where she has this
dissociative identity disorder where one
half is this totally normal nice
character like you see her smiling here
looking at Danny they're probably
helping each other out with something
and then the other side of her
personality is this crazy badass fighter
that has this twist of evil inside of
her like she's going up against Davos so
I'm wondering if steel serpent is gonna
try and take advantage of that because
he has a smile on his face here like
he's trying to convince her to do
something I don't know if they're gonna
give her her special comic book powers
they might just be saying that one half
is like this totally normal nice person
the other half is just this hardcore
badass ninja who's a fighter on par with
steel serpent and iron fist
they play it really real-world so it's
kind of hard to tell whether or not she
will actually get special powers because
they kind of did something like that
during Jessica Jones season 2 where
Trish Walker goes through like this
genetic resequencing that gives her
special powers that they'll be dealing
with in season 3 let's just assume for
now that this version of her character
will be a really badass fighter no
special powers because I think the whole
idea is it's the only real special power
this season is the actual iron fist
itself I'm still kind of wondering if he
takes the power from this desiccated
corpse of the older version of iron fist
instead of taking it from Danny so that
you have two iron fists going at each
other but you can kind of see the way
that they've tuned his fists to be a
little bit redder I think that just to
make it a little bit clearer when they
eventually probably both light up their
fists and start going at each other all
the scenes that they've had in the
trailers Bart Davos lights his fist up
Danny does not light his fist up so I
think they're being a little misleading
with the footage I know you all just
want to know if it's gonna be good or
not like that's the big question is it
good I think just taking them at their
word from the footage we've seen so far
easily vastly better than season 1 I
think you know in terms of how it stacks
up against the other Netflix series
we'll just have to wait and see so just
a reminder all the episodes drop like
Thursday night at midnight next week
I'll post my non-spoilery review as soon
as the embargo is up I think that's on
Tuesday and then I'll start doing the
more spoilery Easter Egg videos and
fight scenes and the cool stuff across
the weekend just leave all your requests
for what kind of iron fist
you guys want me to do next week but
just a reminder that that spider-man ps4
game is also dropping next Friday so
I'll be doing some content for that too
I also have a non-spoilery review
that'll post early sometime next week
but no spoiler alert necessary it's a
really badass game congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Miguel Angel
Ramirez please email me on the back end
of my channel
there'll be a new round when I post new
Marvel I'm working on some new Iron Man
that should post in the next couple of
days but click here for my new Thor Loki
deleted scene video and click here for
brand new spider-man far from home thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight